ابو ليلى من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه السيد
العميد اولا ما هي قراءاتك للمشهد
بدونيسكا
الجمال تزايد العمليات العسكريه او المؤشر
في تسع مناطق مهمه
اكبرها في بخموت لانه مهمه هذا دليل معين
على ان هناك
39.000 جندي روسي ادخلوا الى ساحه المعركه
من اصل 300,000
120,000 دخلوا الى اوكرانيا 39000 في
عمليات عسكريه هذا يدل وحسب الجهه
الاوكرانيه ان هناك ارتفاع في نمط ووثيره
الهجمات
بمعدل 80 هجوم يوميا ولكن دون تحقيق اهداف
مهمه ويبدو على المدى البعيد ان الهدف هو
تثبيت خدي فاعي اولا والتحضير لمرحله قد
تكون لاحقا التركيز اليوم هو على بخموط
لانها في يد فاجنر وليست في يد الجيش
الروسي العادي هل ترى بان هناك مؤشرات على
قرب معركه خيرسون
جمال هناك تحضير لهذه المعركه
كوكا هو مرتبط في خرسان وكما قلت في وقت
سابق هناك احتمالات متعدده لهذه الحرب هل
فعلا الرئيس بوتين يريد التخلي عن خرسان
كما يتم الحديث هل فعلا هذا الجيش الروسي
يخوض عمليه دفاع تاخيري يعني قتال تاخيري
بشكل ان لا يكون هناك انهيار للجبهه طب
لماذا اخلاء المدنيين هل سيكون هناك فعلا
حرب شوارع في هذه المدينه انا في رايي
الخاص ان الرئيس بوتين لن يعطي مكسبا
جديدا لهنسكي خاصه مدينه خرسان لانه هذه
المدينه مهمه رمزيه حتى المنطقه ككل يعني
اقليم خرسان هو مهم بالمعنى الجايه
السياسي الاستراتيجي مدخل الى البحر
الاسود ومدخل الى الجسر البري الذي يصل
القرن
باقليم الدوباس فيمن يتعلق بالجدل الجاري
حول استخدام روسيا لطائرات ايرانيه مسيره
همم لماذا كل هذا الجدل هل كان لهذه
الطائرات المسيره تاثير في هذه المعارك
عبر التاريخ جمال همم الحرب من الجو لم
تاتي بنتيجه عبر التاريخ يعني الذي نعرفه
الحديث وفي كل الحروب ولكن هذه المسايرات
كانت نقطه تعزيز للجيش همم الروسي بضرب
همم البنا التحتيه من طاقه ومياه وبالتالي
شل الحركه الداخليه هذا الجدل هو جدل
سياسي ولكن على الواقع الميداني هناك
وقائع ماديه موجوده ومعروفه واذا كان فعلا
تم شراء هذه المسيارات قبل الحرب فما كان
الهدف من هذه المسيرات واين ستستعمل هل هي
في سوريا ليس هناك من حلب حاليا في سوريا
فاذا كان هناك امر تحضيري ولماذا هناك
خبراء كانوا يدربون الجيش الروسي ان كان
في شبه جزيره القرم او حتى في بلا روسيا
شمال كياف وتصريحات صدرت من المسؤولين في
ايران تقول بانه لم تكن على علم ان هذه
هذه الطائرات المسير استخدم في في في هذه
في هذه المعركه همم هل معنى ذلك ان همم اي
همم مسيرات لم تاتي بعد الان من ايران
يقال حتى الان هناك عقد بين ال 600 وال
2400 مسيره ستباع لروسيا وانا اعتقد اليوم
اذا توقفت هذه الحاله اليوم هناك جمل اعلى
من هذه الموضوع اعلم الموضوع المسيرات
هناك تحالف استراتيجي جيو سياسي مهم جدا
اليوم بين ايران وبين روسيه ينطلق من
سوريا الى همم اوكرانيا وحتى الى الوقوف
في وجه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا
الامر بسيط في العلاقه الجايه والسياسيه
الكبيره واعتقد ان العلاقه هي التي تحكم
اي سلاح ونوع السلاح
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجيه متحدثا من
بيروت السيد العميد شكرا لك